It is, technology and all that stuff,
is really important,
but those can be learned.
I think emotional intelligence
is the key differentiator in the market,
and I think that's true now,
and I think it will be even truer in 10 years.
If you can communicate,
if you can have humility,
if you can have compassion,
if you can make a connection with somebody
in an authentic way,
then I think that you will succeed.
And I think that's absolutely more important
than an incredible CV or resume.
I just think that is vital,
if you can get along with people,
because collaboration is where we are headed,
or we're dead.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.